chaque fois que je vais regarder sera
plateaux télé votre petite touche
personnelle de courir complètement
dessus est ce que depuis que vous avez
totalement arrêtée ou pas ça n'est pas
encore samedi
[Musique]
dernier madonna petite vidéo très
étrange sur instagram mais même on la
voit boire du vin blanc tenir un
discours qui n'a pas de sens regardez
bien le demande de la cocaïne et tous
étaient sinon
j'ai une scène question oppose et
madonna stop ou encore en fait j'avais
encore c'est finement manigances et ça
se voit l effet madonna c'est une rock
star ça fait des années que son fonds de
commerce sexe alcool drogue c'est ce qui
fait d'elle aussi un peu une icône de la
pop donc moi finalement cette vidéo là
elle me choque pas du tout c'est la
continuité de dizaines d'années de
carrière qui qu'ils ou elles sortent
finalement sur ce fond de commerce oui
madonna toujours été trash je suis
totalement d'accord hugo j'ai toujours
été extrêmement fans de madonna quand
elle commence une vidéo en disant je
suis la mère de jésus d'accord on sait
que tu as l'habitude de toute façon pas
là et aussi la religion mais à un moment
donné tu as 63 ballet quoi même si est
fait c'est le fera jusqu'au bout et à
dakwa décousu dingue visiblement mais à
63 ans tu ne peux pas te permettre sur
ces temps compliqués convient d'aller
faire l'apologie de la cocaïne sur
instagram en sachant que tout et
n'importe qui sans logis jacques ok mais
c'est ce qu'elle dit est ce qu'elle dit
prenez la coquette
petite allusion en dix ans elle a déjà
là on parle de ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
montre là qui est assez assez stupéfiant
mais qu'est le dire ça remplace son
talent parce que c'est quand sa dernière
chanson la dernière chanson de madonna
camarades et aux esprits
le cartonné comme avant je suis sûr
qu'elle fera ce débat là
segan mes galas des soeurs et des deux
miss heure et demie les deux mr il ya
une samantha une seule voilà donc méga
delphine émission de télé chez oprah et
elle dit moi je n'ai pas mes demi soeur
je suis un peu genre fils unique j'ai
déjà méconnu donc l'autre samantha la
nuit soeur ali match où nous on est demi
soeur donc on se connaît ll est vexé
qu'est ce qu'elle demande 68000 c'est
précis 65 vraiment 68 mille euros de
dommages et intérêts justement à mes
gars de c'est vrai ça ou diffamation
calomnie atteinte à la vie privée en
effet début mars elle apportait aux
larmes se détestent tous dans cette
famille disons que c'est une famille
13-6 ap le voilà c'est une famille
d'extraction au très modeste et mégane
lorsqu'elle a commencé à avoir cette
tertiaire ferandez et ascension
incroyable ça elle a commencé à faire le
tri est là qu'elle s'est créé une image
meghan markle et pour le coup et bat le
demi-frère la demi-soeur d'étaler le
père aussi a fait un peu tache hossa en
effet de 7 elle a les siennes lâcher un
peu sa famille n'était pas du niveau
royale et la famille se sentait un peu
dénigrer et pourrait connaître a bien
voulu un petit peu dosé absolument et
2017 on apprend donc que les fiançailles
sont en train de se tramer est là la
laddh me sort donc se dit mais moi aussi
je vais avoir un peu ma période de
gloire et elle est invitée en permanence
sur tous les talk shows un peu anglais
où elle commence à parler de sa demi
soeur elle le met simplement de dire que
c'est la demi soeur elle dit que c'est
ma soeur est venue de sa soeur voilà et
à n'est pas qu'elle est plutôt sa part
envers médiane elle parle en effet de
leur enfance qu'elles n'ont jamais eue
ensemble pour le coup et alors là quand
elle ne reçoit pas le carton
d'invitation je me rappelle ken a été
invité jeudi
par exemple tu as vous comprenez ok elle
ne m'a pas invité moi ni mon demi frère
ni mon frère au mariage mais en effet je
lui aurais fait monter dit elle parce
que je suis en fauteuil roulant elle
souffre en est un régal
[Musique]
elisabeth sosie officiel de pamela
anderson au delà des shows et de cette
ressemblance avec lamela anderson elle
avait un autre objectif devenir
chanteuse
alors vous avez été par dont vous avez
été également à rétrécissement vaginale
pourquoi pour le maillot à vrai dire oui
enfin que j'avais fait trop de piercings
j'avais quelques piercing g comment vous
saviez que seulement vous saviez pardon
que pamela avait atteint plus petit club
autres
j'ai vu une vidéo qu'elle avait qu'elle
avait sorti avec la banda avec toi oui
c'est pas me donner d'accord
vous que vous regardez la sextape de
pamela le tome il détient amer d un
centimètre de 30 ans je vivais à chaque
fois que je vais regarder sera plateaux
télé votre petite touche personnelle et
courir complètement dessus est ce que
depuis que vous avez totalement arrêtée
ou pas ça dépend ça n'est pas encore ça
me prend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
ben ali
non mais non mais non rien
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci ma maison
la rumeur marion cotillard et guillaume
canet la séparation on a tout appris
dans boîte si j'ai des supers fiche mais
le mieux pourquoi pas on a un journal
people et si florian ils en sont où
c'est vrai qu effectivement ils se sont
séparés en début d'année pour des
raisons diverses et variées ça faisait
longtemps qu'ils avaient de l'eau dans
le gaz on en avait parlé au moment il y
avait des rumeurs au moment de
rock'n'roll aujourd'hui marion cotillard
serait donc parti elle habiterait chez
une amie lui seraient restés dans leur
bel appartement parisien de l'ouest
parisien d'accord faut dire que notre
ami guillaume canet a un petit peu la
réputation d'être un coureur méconnu
aussi lui l'a beaucoup dit qu'il est
très très difficile à vivre caractère
assez dirigiste et qui n'est pas très
gai dans la vie de tous les jours il
disait toujours je suis né triste je
suis quelqu'un de triste en général dans
la vie de tous les jours etc